never about the song for me
it was you this movie is all about
falling in love while working together
and Freddie we just talked to your wife
of 20 years which is amazing and she
said she's forever indebted to I Know
What You Did Last Summer because that's
where you all met is that where you all
fell in love
no we were just friends man I didn't I
didn't think she ate enough so I made
sure I I cooked for it we were night and
day and it was just our philosophies on
life never clicked and then one day
everything clicked and it was about
probably three years later and we
started dating and she's been my
girlfriend ever since to find a woman
that can't cook and she'll stay with you
forever
very women that come
that can talk about his
about his Netflix why was this holiday
rom-com uh the movie to get you back
into the genre we missed you a little
bit Yeah I appreciate you missing me my
daughter is starting to have an interest
in acting and so my wife and I both kind
of said okay we want to be examples for
that my son could care less he just
wants to race cars and go fast and fun
people
um not the last part so that was the the
one part of it and the main thing was
I don't get to play Latinos very often
in this business so when I get that
opportunity I promise I'm ready ready
plays a single father who falls for his
daughter's favorite singer played by Amy
Garcia I really have to commend Netflix
because the song that Angelina sings was
originally uh Meant To Be Sung in all
English and I pitched them I said hey is
there any way we can just do the final
verse in Spanish as I call my mom and we
translated it together and we sent it to
Netflix and they're like we're keeping
it
done